most fascinating things I ever heard you
talk about was the entrepreneurial
mindset a lot of people kind of look
look at videos on the internet go oh how
can I become an entrepreneur and you
have a totally different take on what
what makes an entrepreneur well I do and
yeah I'm going to sort of invalidate an
entire industry here I think but I don't
think you can actually decide to become
an entrepreneur I think the only way you
could decide to become an entrepreneur
if you could invest in a time machine
I'll explain why so so in all of the
conversations I've had with
entrepreneurs I always ask the same
question I've been very suspicious of
where entrepreneurialism comes from I
think it might be epigenetic so I always
ask the same question is is what did you
do when you were a kid for work and did
you have any challenges or problems when
you were younger but invariably
entrepreneurs will have had difficulties
and challenges in their in their younger
years and the one thing you can
guarantee there that they have hustled
like crazy when they were kids they
would have you know for instance when I
there's the guy does the paper and I was
the guy who marked up the papers before
you got in to do the paper round because
an extra fiver to be had for marking the
papers up did you I used to sell porn
mags at school yeah they used to buy em
cheap and then because we went to a
school and this was in the days of the
internet we used to sell them off from
massive markups to you you obviously
have some entrepreneur we like to
combine both things that roam around the
closest thing I would relate
entrepreneurialism to is is actually
anorexia okay so the latest thinking
about anorexia is is it SEPA genetic and
epigenetic means that circumstances or
the environment cause certain genes to
be expressed that wouldn't of otherwise
or over expressive genes in anorexia
obviously it's the suppression of
appetite which which in which the
environment in the circumstances caused
and you know we're seeing a rapid
increase in in incidence of anorexia at
the same time we've seen a rapidly
increase in the prevalence of social
media social media bullying and so on
and so forth being there the adversity
perhaps that causes the expression of
the gene and I think I suspect something
very similar happens to the entrepreneur
it would make sense for entrepreneurism
to be epigenetic you only want some
people to be entrepreneurial you know if
everybody was entrepreneurial there'll
be chaos
so I yeah I think in terms of the
industry itself or the industry of of
you know self-help books how I made it
you know the baby I basically summarized
the how I made it books is is I went to
this news agent to buy my lottery ticket
that is about the simmer a similar
amount of information that you will get
from from a story about how somebody
made it the only real way to become an
entrepreneur would be to mentor a time
machine travel back in time and
traumatize yourself at the age of eleven
I think you've got so so so I don't
think it's something you can learn I
think it's something that is inherent
and and that that sounds a little bit
unusual but it does explain quite a lot
of behaviors of the of entrepreneurial
people it feels more like a compunction
it feels like you haven't got any choice
it explains why people carry on even
though they've made fantastical amounts
of money which which you often they've
had their liquidity moment they had the
liquidity moment and they're stupid
enough to start another business and do
it all over again
[Music]